Katy Perry dishes on Orlando's Blum Raya
Kari makes one epic clap back plus
christmas came early your first look at
two of the holidays biggest movies now
why is everyone always trying to move
past Thanksgiving to Christmas I'm not
ready this is the daily Denny I'm Denny
direct oh and when I come to terms of
the fact that the holidays are in six
months I am excited to show you guys a
first look at bad mom's Christmas and
the greatest showmen and no I'm not
talking about Beyonce but first we're
going to kick things off with Katy Perry
she's dishing on her number two ranked
ex-lover Orlando Bloom and was now
infamous naked paddleboarding picks Katy
called in to kiss FM Australia's Kyle
and Jackie O on Wednesday where she
admitted that / X also to put on her
birthday suit but she opted to cover up
he asked me if I wanted to be and I just
like you know is one of those things
where I was like no I mean like a result
I mean you know when you when you're
dating someone fun times was deciding to
be like should we try and make out over
here in this place or you know what have
you and I was just not in the mood right
I you know I saved it was boat he was
just trying to show off for all the
people back at the shore she just wasn't
in the mood folks but she doesn't MIT to
stripping down later on their private
yacht but she also joked that she needed
a lot of therapy after those pics
surface Katy in Orlando dated for a
little over a year before calling it
quits last March and speaking of exes
riot Kerry doesn't want you asking about
hers Mimi had the best clap back after
she was asked about her ex-fiance
Australian billionaire James Packer in
Israel take a look
I don't know supposed to know I don't
know well Mariah will not be bothered
with this silly question darling and now
from one diva to another the spirit of
Whitney Houston was alive and well on
America's Got Talent last night you guys
catch this John Emmanuel hit the a GT
stage trying to reclaim his young Fame
he was 14 years old when he was signed
to a record label as a rapper
you got dropped in returned home to his
parents and since then he's clearly had
the bodyguard sound check on repeat
because take a listen to these pipes
this is him Bell T witness I have
nothing
[Applause]
Wow is right paui
but the biggest surprise of the night
came courtesy of a cab driver named
Carlos prepared to be floored by this
Italian cabbies offer covered
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow bellissimo Oh Bravo I'm telling you
guys that is my favorite show of the
summer all right before we go we've got
some exciting movie trailers that just
debut today and for more on that please
welcome to the stage ash crossing
feedback or their greatest showmen I'm
gonna take the best sentence to you that
you've heard today I'm here Hugh Jackman
in a Musical again the greatest showman
Hugh Jackman starring as PT Barnum as in
Barnum and Bailey's circus and this new
trailer is beautiful it's spectacular it
gave me chills
take a look
[Music]
I am here for the groovy music girls
perfect timing out around Christmas time
and also starring Zac Efron zendaya and
Michelle worry I love that also out
around that time you bad mom sequel bad
mom's Christmas et debuted the first
look and not only are they bringing in
more moms the ladies are really opened
up to crazy and here's the truth
see here we go I don't think I can do
this over guys when I get drunk at the
food court yeah I do
how high some people have been so easy
to do like bad moms does Hawaii or bad
mom says Vegas and then use replicated
this is just the women a year later
exactly your later to the timeline will
be the same and it's them doing
Christmas together
I spend months picking out the perfect
present for everyone you know the only
thing I get in return
coupons free back rub that's not okay
bad back rub take Christmas back it's
great because we didn't want to just do
the same movie again
so rather than deal with the stresses of
school it deals with the stresses of the
holidays but our mothers come in town
okay so it's this added layer of not
only are we overworked moms were also
bratty children at the same time Susan
Sarandon Cheryl Hines and Christine
Baranski
joined the festive follow up as naughty
grandma Cheryl Hines explain your momma
what was your reaction to that so
perfect I would I love Cheryl you're
like who do you want and as I be risking
my mom where's your truth I didn't like
waste time Christmas tree shopping I
actually wanted to enjoy Christmas this
year baby you are a mom moms don't enjoy
they give joy that's helping a mom or
fuh ha ha I feel like that to me as a
mom I don't hurt your grandma I love
that I'm not a mom thank you so much for
hanging out with us today asked you guys
can catch more of her at ATT at the
movies there's a new episode up tomorrow
this guy's got to be on it yeah talking
spider-man
if I ask are you guys that's it for us
today but be sure to hit subscribe on e
t--'s youtube channel for more daily
deni tomorrow ET at the movies lots
going on and of course head over to ET
online.com for all the greatest
entertainment headlines of the day
alright we'll see you tomorrow
goodbye